turkish President Recep Tayyip Erdogan
says the military offensive in Syria is
not a land grab he's criticized anchors
allies for not supporting what he calls
a fight against terrorists Salim Kassab
who is in Istanbul for us so Sinan he's
going to go to Sochi we know tomorrow is
that basically a preview of his message
well yeah actually president Ireland
once again repeated the same messages
that he has been giving for a while as
you said telling that Turkey doesn't
have any aim of territorial gain in
Syria and a turkey is just after the
report after protecting the rights of
the Syrian civilians who took refuge in
Turkey after the civil war started in
Syria and he emphasized again that the
deal that he made with the United States
is a state-to-state deal turkey didn't
sit around the table with what turkey
calls a terrorist organization which is
the YPG as the offshoot of the Kurdistan
Workers Party for Turkey and he repeated
the same thing and he actually the
countdown has started and all officials
have been saying today including a
foreign minister Javad shoulder tomorrow
around a turkey local time 8:00 p.m.
which is around 32 hours something like
that the temporary ceasefire is going to
expire and it will depend on it will
depend how whether the the SDF forces
the YPG forces will completely withdraw
from the designated safe zone or not of
course this is important tomorrow is
important for Turkey because the Astana
trio Russia Turkey and Iran have been
working on for a political solution
inside Syria and Syria is also a party
in this in a sochi meeting and at the
end of October October 30 there will be
the Geneva talks where they will discuss
about the future of Syria
so this constitutional committee that
Russia and Turkey agreed on including
Iran and that they announced in in the
Turkish capital Ankara a few weeks ago
it's going to be an important step and
Turkey Russia and Iran are trying to
work out a political solution process
for Syria that's why through Sochi
President aired on aims to have a
successful game in Geneva talks for
Syria in terms of political solution but
of course again he repeated the same
messages because today in today's
organization and some of the speakers
who were invited they canceled their
they canceled their speeches because of
turkeys military operation in Northeast
Syria against YPG and aired on accuse
those people for supporting terrorism
and not supporting for democracy I'm
gonna strike still trying to explain his
country yeah if I could just get in the
the US is confirmed that some of its
forces are actually gonna stay in Syria
to try and control some of the country's
oil fields and the indication how Turkey
might deal with that might react to that
well the US troops are at the beginning
the US troops announced that they pulled
out from the designated safe zone which
is thirty two kilometers from Turkey
southern border to down south and the US
forces are there and when you cause when
you just go back to what US Vice
President Mike Pence said after their
meeting with air Don and the turkish
capital ankara last week he said from
now on we are not militarily engaged
with the SDF so they cut their military
support but of course as also US
president Trump has stated before they
will keep on coordinating still they see
the SDF as a very instrumental tool in
the fight against ISIL inside Syria and
Turkey so this is actually an important
step for Turkey as well but as I said
everything depends on what they are
going to be discussing with Russia and
Iran tomorrow in Sochi all right thanks
so much sin of course although there